thank you for joining us America we're
glad you are here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions Dave and Terra are with us hey
guys how are ya hey Dave good how are
you welcome I like your t-shirts got
some gazelle shirts on for those of you
that can't see through your radio you're
watching on YouTube or whatever we so
love them very cool
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream we are where are you from
Wellington Florida right outside of West
Palm oh cool
very nice and how much dad have you paid
off one hundred and seven thousand seven
hundred and sixty one hundred seven
hundred sixty one dollars and 59 cents
good job all right very nice how long
did that take
28 months that's quick range of income
during that time we started around 80
and through this process in the 28
months we're about at 130 Wow
substantial races where the razors come
from I just just work stuff and God just
blessing this whole thing Wow very cool
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
I'm in Human Resources I work for a
health care company and Tara I was
working in payroll and then slowly I've
moved to being back at home with the
kids okay
very cool good that's neat yeah so what
kind of debt was the 108 thousand Oh
Lord bad decisions credit cards to cars
we had some medical bills that range
back to our older son when he was in his
teens and we were just continuously
making bad decision after bad decision
in fact the Friday before we took
Financial Peace University I was at a
dealership ready to buy a new car I
didn't know I was taking a financial
piece by the way I had no idea
I'm Tara signed us up and Holloway she
just announced to you here we go sign up
in church and said hey by the way I'm
doing a financial piece and if you want
to come along you know come along and
enjoy married you'll come along yeah
okay so you guys wander into class Tara
what made you sign up for a financial
piece I just heard about it so long ago
about 18 years ago my brother-in-law and
my sister kind of told us about you and
it's always been on my heart and I kept
asking Dave you want to come and he's
like
no absolutely not I do not want to do
that I know where my money's going
mm-hmm
and finally I just said I had it I'm
going and so you can either come or you
can just pick me up after but I need to
learn some more about this because we're
just going backwards that's known as the
Holy Spirit telling me to show up I got
you brother I got you
so you wander into class a bit
reluctantly to say the lead yep
and maybe even more than a little bit
yeah and so how did the first class go
well I had my back to the whole table we
had a table of 10 or our one of our
pastors is sitting at our table going
through it I'm sure that not I'm sure
everyone that took that class said man
we didn't think you're gonna make it to
week 2 cuz I was just mad hmm but inside
it was stirring like I don't know what
I'm doing I I've made bad decisions it's
time to change my for my future so so
you roll in that you rollin the next
week ready ready to go a little bit more
I was still acting like I didn't want to
be there until week three but I did have
fun with the free spirit part and then
you know the nerd part that that's where
I just hooked on and went and changed
our lives so I just started making sense
and really God's Spirit was just working
on that yeah changed our marriage man
changed it a bit
very cool yeah how long you guys been
married 22 years Wow and he he we just
knocked 34 out the other day so we're a
little ahead of it yes that's very cool
well congratulations and then so then
you you know as you week three hits so
now you're really starting to get on
board and then you go okay we're gonna
do this and Tara I have a feeling that
when Dave does something he doesn't
sorta do something he does it all the
way am i right yeah that's kind of
because he like didn't sorta didn't want
to go
he's not real pliable he just whatever
he's gonna do he's gonna do right or
wrong yeah so when he's in he's in so
now it's it's a wide open I'm guessing
that's right that's right in and we
teach it and I know we're very involved
with so now you teach the glass of God
has a sense of humor doesn't he because
it's also I'd never would
I'd be teaching financial piece in 1
million years what you Church are you in
we're at Christ Fellowship how are you
okay all right yeah we love those guys
they have some very good good friends
were really good folks yeah all right
fun and that's thus the gazelle t-shirt
being coordinated that's right that's
right yep very neat fun so now that
you're teaching it and you've come the
full circle from being the ultimate
reluctant spouse and all the way around
what is your advice to people who want
to get out of debt what are the one of
the main things they have to know don't
wait don't wait because you mention it
in class that's it's it could save your
marriage and it did ours listen to the
principles but put God first and when
you put God first amazing things happen
Wow
and you turn into a selfless instead of
a selfish person
Wow don't look at that number that that
big number because we were like way at
the bottom of the class but don't look
at that number and say I can never get
to that number because we've just made a
chart and we said we'll start the first
month was like this much and finally we
got to the top of the chart and that's
what kept us going and doing our budget
don't waver from it do it do it do it
every month
in fact we adopted proverbs 10:4 this is
lazy hands make for poverty but diligent
hands bring wealth or prosperity so
we've adopted that we teach it that way
absolutely and we're seeing lives change
all over our church man it's awesome
that's very cool yeah yeah
so Tara how much of a change of you
seeing this guy here all the emotion in
his voice so much it's really awesome to
see and to see where we were and where
we are today and just a tad over two
years yeah that's amazing turnaround we
projected to August to be done but our
son was coming here for a band camp a
Christian band came oh cool and we said
we were gonna be in Tennessee so
everything we had we just put everything
into our final bill the last two months
like we've had no spending money we
haven't done anything
I gave plasma money
on vacation I mean Here I am making a
hundred plus and I'm giving plasma for
money but you do what you got to do to
get past past the next goal because we
want to get to step three and we still
want to buy a home because we had to
short sale home some years Gil yeah now
your son's with you what's his name and
how old is he
JT and he's 14 all right so your my kids
have begun 3 24 21 and 14 all right so
JT's watched all this happen yeah big
time see is he been seeing really what's
going on is he just watching from a
distance he's seen it in he's on a he's
on his own little budget trying to get
his guitar you know his budget for his
guitar that he wants and he's trying to
work that way and he also is on
commission plan so when he does his
chores he gets paid and when he doesn't
he doesn't get paid
he loves FPU for that part gives him a
tractor run off yeah it does yeah it
does well well done you guys I'm very
very proud of you you're heroes man
thinking more than that even more than
that your turn on teaching other people
that's just very very cool yeah we love
it neat story all right Dave and Tara
and JT from West Palm Beach Florida man
that's right a hundred and eight
thousand paid off in 28 months making
eighty two hundred and thirty a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream ready way to go you guys that is
awesome
very nice you know I'll never forget the
first day I was teaching the class I
used to teach it live Financial Peace
University with an overhead projector in
a bad suit and the first day this couple
stopped me in the hall after the class
is over and they said you know you saved
our marriage don't you maybe this is a
financial class were talking about
mutual funds and budgets and they said
now you taught us how to work together
and how to how to talk about this stuff
and I went I did and I kept hearing that
over and over and over and over and it's
turned out to be one of the biggest
benefits of Financial Peace University
is the impact on people's marriages for
those that are married those that are
single obviously it gives you control
and other things but not only getting
out of that me on a budget but if for
you two work together and it forces so
many couples to heal broken spots in
their relationships it's so powerful God
really uses it in that way this class
has taught all over America you need to
get in one if you hadn't been through it
what are you waiting on oh my goodness
just go Deb Ramsay calm get signed up
it's time people it's your time this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind